california has long been a leader in
agriculture but one crop that's never
been commercially viable anywhere in the
continental u.s is coffee until now
jamie wax has the story jamie good
morning good morning anthony the coffee
market is estimated to be an 81 billion
dollar industry coffee has grown in more
than 50 countries and now a farmer just
outside santa barbara has the coffee
world buzzing the question is whether
americans will pay the same for a
high-end cup of coffee as they would for
a glass of that california chardonnay
high above the pacific ocean in goleta
california referred to by locals as the
good land jay ruske has been farming the
land for 25 years growing an eclectic
mix of tropical crops from avocados to
passion fruit to dragon fruit so how
many acres is this farm in total
this farm is 42 acres but about half of
it is dedicated to agriculture it's a
long two and a half mile ride down this
narrow country road just to make it off
the mountain it's all precision
so having coffee around the house is
convenient but reski has taken that to a
whole new level this is the
our um geisha coffee and and i want you
to
take a little whiff of that you can oh
boy
wow
this geisha was grown here on his farm
it's a layered agricultural system ruski
and his colleague lindsey mesta showed
us some of the approximately 1500 coffee
trees kept shaded by larger fruit trees
you can actually see coffee blossoms
yeah
forming along the stem here and each of
these flowers will eventually become
a coffee cherry which has two seeds in
those cherry seeds are what we know as
beans
so take a coffee cherry and just pop it
in your mouth
okay
it's very spicy
it's almost got like a mild pepper taste
another little sweetness to it that
sweetness is what we
need for a really good cup of coffee but
the land in the continental united
states has never been hospitable for
growing coffee because the cherries
mature faster in the heat coffee is
traditionally produced in hot climates
adding shade or elevation slows down the
process but increases the quality
why do you think no one's ever tried it
before in california the main reason is
that there wasn't a market for it now
there's a new giant-sized instant
maxwell house a really big jar of coffee
for decades coffee was packaged and sold
to the masses as an inexpensive
commodity we make it a special way so
you can save money
[Music]
great coffee beginning in the late 60s
companies like pete's and starbucks
brought in a second wave focusing on
quality and the cafe experience in 2002
this third wave movement of coffee shops
that had smaller roasters wanted to know
where their coffee was coming from share
their experience with the consumer and
the consumers were paying a little more
for that so about 10 years ago an
audacious idea began brewing for ruski
when you started
thinking about this and developing this
did people tell you you were crazy to
think of growing coffee in california
yes
there's a weekly event for people to
call i had to have people call on the
phone and it'll be the first two
sentences you know they'd say hey you're
jay rescue yeah
you're you're crazy you can't be growing
coffee outside all right it's rapid seed
development for sure okay this year
ruski teamed up with charlie habiger of
blue bottle coffee which operates 48
cafes in cities around the us and tokyo
looks like you're going to be ready to
pick again in two months they're going
to slow down and work on quality and so
we're really eight months away
habiger travels five months a year
purchasing coffee in places like
ethiopia guatemala uganda and sumatra
the northern california native had been
tracking ruski's path from afar jay's
coffee objectively can compete with the
best coffees in the world right so this
isn't just support for the coffee
because it's coming from california but
it is a a strong valuation that we want
to make on this market on behalf of
consumers so that we can have that
conversation with people about why
coffee costs what it costs blue bottle
purchased ruski's entire 2017 crop
300 pounds we were there when the
shipment left for the roasting facility
in oakland
it will be sold in blue bottles across
the country for 16 dollars a cup
habiger says blue bottle is not just
selling a cup of coffee but the story of
where it came from but for many american
consumers they just got used to a three
dollar four dollar cup of coffee for the
average person where does that land i
think if you walk into a cafe and if you
see you know 275 350 450 18
right
the first thing that you're going to
need to know to make sense out of that
18 cup is why is it so expensive after
significant investments in research and
development it costs ruski approximately
thirty dollars a pound to produce and
blue bottle sixty five dollars a pound
to purchase and if you drink coffee and
if you do have a couple of moments to
reflect on where it comes from exactly
how it tastes you know maybe why it
tastes that way if roasters are doing a
good enough job of helping you
understand it then i think it's a really
easy step to take all right so this is
my favorite parts my kids favorite parts
the bloom when it's really fresh coffee
it explodes and bubbles just like what
just happened here
it's nice the whole ritual of the coffee
making
the anticipation for the cup
piping hot piping hot
very smooth
really delicious ruski's new venture
fringe coffee is working closely with
farmers throughout southern california
to make the entire region a coffee
powerhouse it's just like wine you know
if you have a really good wine crop
there are people out there that want to
experience what you've been working hard
on and that's what we're offering when
you look ahead
what does success look like to you
southern california is well known for
having the most rarest and flavorful
cups of coffees in the world that would
be ultimately successful for me
and then you'd figure out another crazy
idea i think probably
[Laughter]
jay ruski's good land organic coffee
will be available at blue bottle later
this month you'd think when the coffee
came here the price would go down not up
that's true i gotta say jamie for 16
bucks i want a dozen amazing donuts
[Laughter]
i will say it it was possibly the best
cup of coffee i've ever had it was very
very special it's an incredible i didn't
bring any free samples i'm noting
all right i hope you heard us there
goodland so
jamie
thank you my friend thank you